hey guys maybe this is because I'm a
girl but I always used to think about
the day I'd meet the one someday they'll
be your arms that's real that's that's
not even a cutaway it's more like a
flashback of my life when I was 13 I was
literally like obsessed with finding
love you I'm gonna practice with my
pillow I may have found the love of my
life but the search good god man the
search for true love is fucking hard
baby it's not what it looks like you
bastard you're cheating on me with a
heart she's not even cute
I know ah so what do you do
hopefully you Wow don't so let's just
clarify the contract terms okay uh so
you'll stay over your soul if I bring
you a man who's hard-working funny
generous kind intelligent and loves
love's loves cats and well-endowed not
like insane or anything but you know
occasionally it can be uncomfortable but
overall it's just do not only is it hard
to find love but you have to know how to
keep it kiss me you fool
but no matter what happens never give up
because the search and the wait are
worth it trust me
so stay off and Gotham never give up
because the search ah someone is calling
me hi baby yeah good I'm good and
blogging
I didn't say doing laundry I said
vlogging no no I think that is a
Freudian slip bit is that a hint that
you want me to do laundry
Jesus man I'm just talking about true
love and you want me to do your laundry
I'm just kidding I'm kidding I'm giving
you a hard time
I'm kidding now I love you I